[Music]
every single day i look at what is being
wasted and i find a way to actually put
it back in the circle we call this
circular economy so the idea is to
create value out of waste
my name is david cote i'm co-founder of
luke mission
so loot mission started five years ago
we basically rescue food every day and
make different products out of it so we
rescue
produce and we make cold pressed juice
out of them and then when our own pulp
and fiber is reused after to actually
make your dog treats we've launched a
line of beer made out of the old bread
we have a gin made out of potato
cuttings we have soap made with
discarded oil from a fast food chain we
look at waste and we try to find
solution to put it back in on the on the
shelves in the grocery store and create
value out of it
so what's amazing with our products is
that we have a flavor profile that is
different in our competition in the
industry when you make a product we have
to look at costing all the time and make
sure your casting is as low as possible
so if i take cold press juices for
example most of our computer on the
market use the same thing cucumber
celery
carrot and beets things that are not too
pricey we work with overstock so we have
access to clementine fresh grapes fennel
honeydew melon things that normally you
wouldn't see in a culprit juice because
most of companies can't afford it
[Music]
food waste
is a huge cause of greenhouse gas
emissions because when you send food to
the landfill even though instinctively
you think it's the most natural thing
you can send to the landfill it's
actually the worst thing we can send
because it doesn't decompose because we
fill the lamb so it creates a lake civic
which is a basically an acidic
liquid that contaminates biodiversity so
by stopping food waste we're stopping a
huge cause of greenhouse gas emission
and kind of giving us a little chance
for the future
i always felt like i wanted to do
something for the planet i realized that
the best thing you can do is start a
business that actually change the world
and change the environment because
that's where money is at and money
change the world you have to talk to
their pockets
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll say we pay about
35 to 40 the price that the normal
company will pay for normal produce high
price but we think that's the best
reward we can give to companies that
wants to look at their food waste and
wants to try to find a solution with us
not too long ago sobey that i wanted
carrots that they wanted to give us and
i said no we'll buy this van from you
because this is what we want to teach
people there's value in this waste
the difference with a linear company and
a circular economy company is that we're
not really looking for a gap in the
market we're looking at a problem and we
need to find a solution so every product
we launch we always have to look at what
is being wasted to create this product
take the gin for example someone called
me and said they're throwing away potato
cuttings so we went and visit looked at
what it looked like and then started
calling a few people in r d to see what
we could do with potato cuttings realize
we could make a gin so we sent it to a
distillery then we tested with buyers in
the market to see if there was an
interest
every single product is like this
and we want to replicate this model all
around the world right it doesn't make
sense to export our products to europe
or australia or even mexico or even
california because there's so much
transportation in need and and the waste
is everywhere so our idea is to actually
replicate this model and create a
factory just like we have here
all around the world
i feel every single day that i wake up
and i go to bed that i did something
that is satisfying right and we have
this calculator online that calculates
live how much we're saving and what what
kind of impacts it has on embedded water
and greenhouse gas emission and so i
feel that i'm actually doing my part and
so yeah i'm very very satisfied
[Music]
[Laughter]